was the worst interview you ever did i  mean the one that comes to mind is when  i interviewed boonk  and he shows up and he's like blackout  drunk or on pills we had an agreement  for him to do an interview but we're  live i can't get him to not come on  camera i keep telling him no i'm not  interviewing you like this and he's like  come on come on we're gonna do it and  then he sits down he does this interview  it's so [ __ ] stupid it's just him  repeating himself over and over and then  when he gets up to leave he [ __ ]  collapses and smashes his forehead on  the wall and like i'm in hawaii the next  week and some [ __ ] waiters like i  loved when that guy passed out in his  head